UFC picks uh allergy alert Oliveira  [Music]  Mecca cheva here's a guy that ran  through Bobby green right ah [ __ ] that  guy's a scary [ __ ] who knows I  would I would more than likely pick  Islam in that in that fight but at the  same time you know I I also believe that  Charles is the most dangerous guy not  just that 155 but probably in the whole  UFC based on his versatility and his  skill sets in not only Jiu Jitsu but his  striking he's getting really dangerous  too but  Islam Islams who had picked to win that  one if I had to and I think taking down  Charles is actually going to be a  mistake and I have Oliveira's probably  right now the best Grappler actively  competing right now in MMA that fight's  going to be spectacular because neither  of those guys neither Islam nor Charles  has faced someone with a skill set that  is specifically designed to shut down  the skill set of the other person that's  gonna be a great matchup